[Music]
uh this is the episode of data Council
live with soda in as a co-presenter I'm
very excited to be here and talk about
data contracts we have some renowned
experts in the field with us today and
very grateful for them to share their
knowledge and wisdom um with the
community so I'm going to kick it off
and and actually have them introduce
themselves briefly um so that we all
know who they are and what their
involvement in data contracts is um
let's kick it off with
Andrew yeah hi everyone uh I'm Andrew
I'm based in the UK and I'm principal
engineer and I I guess I kind of created
data contracts a few years ago as a way
to describe how I wanted to build data
platforms and change dat culture so I've
been thinking about dat contracts quite
a long time um and early this year I got
opportunity to write a book about dat
quality and date contract so I'm for as
right
now and Andrew where are you currently
working I work for aany go caros inch B
UK great
JG yeah so I'm JG or je George and uh
I'm a lifetime IBM Champion I'm the
chair of the ble steering committee uh
which B is uh is hosting the odcs open
data contract St
uh part of the Linux Foundation I'm also
as a chief Innovation officers at ABA
data that's my current job and offers of
multiple books and I promised my wife
I'd do less in
2024 I probably won't drop Lego
playing great
Max hey folks I'm Max I'm currently
associate director of Eng data
engineering at hellofresh um where I'm
leading the data platform form and I've
basically been like working on data
platforms both at hellofresh as well as
previously at zando um and always had a
strong focus on like building tools that
allow people to work better with data
and that has directly driven me into the
hands of data contracts as well uh
previously been very very active about
the data mesh topic as well um done a
lot of trainings and uh written on that
topic as well uh but yeah for the past I
would say nine months I guess since I
joined Tesh I've been very very actively
working on data contracts and practice
so happy to be here today and share some
of my
experiences great and Tom yeah hi thanks
for having me and uh I'm a co-founder of
ncdo of soda and I've been a longtime
software engineer and so now after uh
being the creator of sorta um data
contracts enforcement engine I think uh
it's it's good inspiration that software
engineering background to see what data
actually can gain from everything all
the knowledge there that we've builded
up over the years and I think in data um
some of those aspects make sense to
translate there so that's uh that's
basically my
mission great well thanks again to you
all for for being here um I want to kick
things off and get into a definition of
data contracts because I noticed that
there's no lawyers on the panel so
apparently data contracts or not some
weighty Tom like legal agreement that
we're all entering into um rather what
what are data contracts um obviously
it's a term that's become popular in the
last couple years um you know I'd be
curious to get the panelist take on
what's in scope and what's out of scope
um for data contracts for this
discussion yeah I can go with a a
definition um I think dat contracts res
few ways to look at it but I think one
of the things is they are the interface
for data so there a way you make data
available to other people in your
organization to build upon um if you're
familiar with things like data products
using data product terminology then you
can say it's a thing about Mak data dat
product available to us so you can late
products um but yeah Prim the interface
that allows data to be made available to
be built upon
confidence
cool
data sorry data products becoming
available to to others in the work um
sorry uh someone else is going to jump
in yeah yeah definitely so API for data
I think that's really uh that's really
an interesting take uh and that that
kind of resonates for me as well as uh
being a past before I went to the data I
was in the software engineer and there
like API is um and let's say yeah apis
as well as on a component level as on
microservices for instance all about
encapsulation and I think that's exactly
uh what we need in data and that's why I
think uh contracts is going to be kind
of like revolutionary because like we we
didn't have this in in Data before and
the API API for data is more like look
when you make data available to someone
you do it as a data set or a table or
something of that nature and then
whatever the implementation was doesn't
really matter and then this is this is
your interface and now you as a client
or a consumer how am I going to consume
this data so that's essentially what a
contract is it describes to any user to
uh be able to get started with consuming
data and and this is also um like an
interface where the the software
interfaces have for instance HTTP as a
basis well this this is quite different
in data and that's why data needs a
different kind of interface because
you're working with the warehouse or the
database driver protocol uh and the way
you consume it is not by Json in Json
out but it's more like you you send a
SQL query over that specific protocol
and you get a bunch of data coming back
and you need to know like the columns
and schema and all that so in that sense
it's a new way to define an interface
and how to consume data and I think it's
going to enable um encapsulation and
therefore they have the same effect as
um object-oriented programming or um
like micros Services had on the software
engineering space I think this is the
same is going to happen here as well
enabling much much larger um yeah
projects and and scalability of data
where now things get clogged down very
fast but probably talking way too long
here so before I get I just wanted to to
to jump on one point there as well like
um an interface also always means that
it's a it's a a tool for communication
and collaboration right like it's it's
really about like where basically you
have like a clearly defined language
with which people are now speaking to
each other and that language happens to
be easily understandable for the people
as well as for the machines um because
that makes it such that you can actually
like add some Automation and some
enforcement around that instead of just
putting a piece on paper um and signing
it off and then throwing it away and not
looking at it anymore in two months
right so like that that's like one of
the key aspects for me as well that we
are structuring the communication around
data um by giving like a very structured
way on how people are interacting with
each
other and and so to that point I'm
wondering um is there a minimum siiz
organization that benefits from data
contracts is there a minimum size um you
know scope or sprawl of sort of the the
data projects a team is working on um
I'm just curious in in sort of the real
world
um in the panelist estimation like
when's the right time for a team to
start to look at data contracts what
what's the sign that something is bad
enough or um what are the indicators
that a team should start to look at um
investing in in data contracts in their
own
order do you have a do you have a do you
have a pipeline do you use a data
pipeline then if you do if you use a
data pipeline you should be doing data
contracts that's that's as a early as it
as it starts okay um I think that the
data contract is really the link between
the producers the producer of the data
and the consumer of the data it it's a
link also between the physical and The
Logical world and it's a definition not
only of the metadata but the meta
metadata and by meta metadata I I think
about the quality
the and all this this behavior of the
data itself okay so I I think it's
critical to start as early as possible
to be doing data contracts uh it
clarifies things uh as as Max said it's
it's a wonderful tool for
communication um but this you know you
can have communication problem with a
team of five
so yeah I'd agree I think if you're
going to try and do something your data
you want to be reliable and you want it
to be built forward
medium to long term then you probably
want you need that contract mandate if
you're otherwise it's just not it's just
not going to beable it's you can't build
confidence and and that of course also
doesn't mean that you start with like a
10 page data contract for like the first
table that you put in your organization
right it's like like you start with like
the the minimum that makes sense for you
right like and and like to be honest
even just
documenting how certain tables named and
where to find it is like that that can
be the First Data contract that you have
right as long as you like note that down
somehow and then you like extend that
over time because your team of five
might not have a communication problem
yet if they do maybe you have other
things to tackle um but that team of
five will be 15 at some point will be 50
the next day um at some point you will
start having like more distribution more
friction uh and you need to you can no
longer just rely on verbal communication
um and then every single bit that you
have put down in your initial very
simple version of a data contract
originally um is documentation that will
make sure that your organization can
still work also once it outgrows this
like mini signup phase it's it's an
iterative process okay as you said max
the thing is you start by basic
information you keep adding uh and it
becomes richer and richer and to another
thing to to what Max said regarding the
the organization it's not only about the
team growing it's also about the team
leing and new people coming in so it's
it's this
continuation of I I I'm always wondering
if it's a politically correct term these
days but it's a this tribal knowledge
that you've got into the Enterprise that
you can finally document okay and and
this is oh I know that Andrew wrote this
thing okay so I can ask a question even
if Max is a new owner of the of the
contract because Max could be on
vacation or it's a doctor this
afternoon so so as we're lingering on um
sort of defining you know data contracts
and and and setting up the rest of our
conversation um I'm excited to get into
a bunch of implementation questions um
with you guys but I wanted to First just
mention that you know one of the
Hang-Ups that um I hear from folks in
the community um especially those of us
who've been in data a while um you know
uh interestingly enough is how is a data
contract different than a schema because
I think we have this sort of um Baseline
understanding of you know what a proper
data scheme looks like or what proper
normalization looks like um and we're
all used to sort of the the relational
database um model in in most cases um so
I I just wanted to like step off from
there and um and and Pa the POS the
question to you all um how do you
explain to folks that that data
contracts is is is more really more than
just a scheme
yeah to me the the contract is the
extension of the schema because the
schema itself is not enough it's it's a
great basis if you know that's where the
table is and you know like okay these
are the columns and this is the data
types you already technically can access
the data but then again like there's a
lot of farar out there um what's in it
what's the format and for some
applications that doesn't make a lot of
difference but for most data
applications it does and then it's
important that you understand that data
at a much deeper level and that's
exactly where data contracts go beyond
what the the database schema can give
you yeah I'd agree I think yes extension
of a schema it's also date contract will
have things like schema management and
you can evolve a date contract without
breing everything think Downstream so
you have some sort of migration there um
if you have a scheme that can change any
time you can change database then that's
not going to be something you can build
on easily at least not if you want
something to be reliable for any period
of time so you have to have some kind of
interface that goes beyond just a table
and that handles it's version it's got a
migration path you can make non-breaking
changes to it but breaking changes have
some migration path to it all those kind
of things you need again VY works very
well like um all kind of things you need
if you want to build on something
with any
confidence I I want to acknowledge um
something that uh JG put out um in the
open data contract standard which I
found helpful um perhaps we can paste
this the URL to the project um in the in
the show notes but um it was helpful to
me to understand just sort of looking at
the the open data contract standard the
table of content the table of contents
um which sort of explain very quickly at
a high the scope of what's what's being
discussed and there are things like data
sens and schema data quality pricing
stakeholders roles SLA service level
agreement um Etc so I I I I appreciated
um understanding um sort of having a
more um expanded mental model of
everything that can go into Data
contracts and um I know um this standard
o odcs is something that um we'll be
talking about today so I just wanted to
to tip off the attendees to that and say
that there's a good body of work that's
been um popping up under that project um
JJ do you want to quickly introduce the
project and and tell us how it started
yeah so so so ODS odcs is now part of a
project called Bol which is hosted by
the Linux Foundation um and and the idea
was I've seen data contracts in many
many forms okay from I code to excel
sheets to Word document to paper in
Pages where people were signing stuff
okay uh and there was really a need for
if we want to create real value around
the data contract is to let's make them
standard or as standard as possible and
uh so first when I was working with a
with a financial institution uh we open
source a data contract template and uh
from there basically the the nonprofit
Ida user group and U the Linux
Foundation took over to create this uh
this open data contract standard
odcs and uh we we are like 15 members on
the steering committee on the technical
steering committee um Andrew is part of
it Tom is also part of it uh I am I've
got the honor of chairing the committee
and um we we're just new okay so the
thing is there's more room for more
people Max please join us um and uh and
and we need also a little bit more we
need more women because it's very male
and uh so we need we need we need to
expand our Horizon a little bit but
anyway so the thing is this the idea of
that is to create uh there's kind of
three group of of people in the steering
committee you've got users you've got
service companies and you've got vendors
okay so typically soda is is one vendor
that is part of this steering committee
and driving kind of the adoption of the
the data quality component of those uh
of this of this standard okay and as you
said Pete there's eight there's eight
blocks in the data contract that
correspond to eight kind of needs around
that okay and schema is part of it
schema is one okay but there's seven
others yeah and I wanted to uh expand a
bit on why this actually is important I
think because like the data stack at
this moment is super fragmented there's
loads of small tools there's not like
there's big platforms as well but
there's a lot of tools that you as a
data practitioner have to Cobble
together and the data contract there and
the the initiative um with Bol is all
about like if you start from the schema
and all of the other factors around it
like there's million tools that can
benefit
from the schema and having extra
configuration information in the schema
or embedded in that schema file and that
that's essentially is uh what this
initiative is doing it's enabling uh a
language that you don't have clashes
between the tools and that you have like
a Common Language to express all those
different um those different aspect used
by different tools so that all the
different tools can use the same
contract file um and I think that's
going to be very valuable going forward
well we definitely need more vendor
neutral standards organizations um in
the community and at data Council we've
always supported um vendor neutrality
and um appreciate seeing the community
come together um to build these
standards so um this is definitely a
standard that we want to um you know
promote and and and represent to our
community as well so I'm glad that um we
have the the author here and uh
participating so thank you JG for that
that um someone asked a question in the
chat which I think is particularly um
pertinent for for this level of
conversation um what's the kind of
information that can be stored in the
data contract can it be business rules
for data sets um I think the answer is
definitely yes but I wanted to let the
panelists um take a shot at
that Max any any thoughts yeah like um
as we already touched upon before like a
data contract is like something that um
that that it evolves iteratively right
like you start with something very
simple like a schema definition for
instance um together with like I don't
know some some ownership information uh
some information about like where to
find the data to begin with um you add
some things on top of that like like
slos slas um uh and then you keep on
expanding keep on adding like more uh
advanced concepts for that and like for
what I've seen so far um that's usually
where most stop at the moment but not
because I think that's where we should
stop but because we are just not there
yet in terms of the iteration um so like
right now for instance the data
contracts that I'm working with um is is
pretty much covering like what I what I
just said um but I very much foresee
this advancing further um to actually
have um no longer just data contracts
but entire data product definitions um
to be following the same format as we
currently do with data contracts right
that you have something that where you
basically just fill out a template um
and that includes your business rules
your business logic um so that you can
um produce a new data product based on
the the specifications that you've
actually given in and um we're by far
not there yet um for instance at the
moment at hellofresh we have like a
separate project that is doing exactly
that second part to do like template
driven data development I guess um and
then we attach data contracts to that as
a second component but I very much
forese that those two things will merch
in the
future I find it interesting that we're
that we're talking about data products
um like it's come up several times
already in the conversation um are we
all in agreement that um data contracts
in an ideal world would drive data
products or is there any any
disagreement on that
point there's no disagreement just to
reinforce that I
think you will need if you want to think
about data product you will need data
contracts right so it's a kind of a
requirements this way around you can
have as as you asked earlier okay the
basic thing is you've got a data
pipeline a data contract will already
already bring a lot of value to you but
if you want to go towards a data product
you will require data contract and
probably more than one and then if you
want to go to the next step which is
data mesh for me then you will
definitely require even more data
contracts
so um well let's let's switch gears and
start to talk about um data contracts
more in practice in the or um who owns
the data contract and who wants to own
the data contract and who should own the
data
contract just that I'm not sure there's
anyone that wants to own it that's
that's but H you get well you can it's
all about incentives as always but um I
think the owner has to be the people who
produce data um only they can really
like influence the quality of data only
they know have full context of the data
um yeah only they can really own dat
contract no one else can you can't have
someone else own a DAT contract or
someone El data because what incentive
have they got to meet your
contract there's a collaboration there
so I think it has to be data producer in
a is owned by the producing team exactly
the same um in terms of whether they
want to I that just comes down to
incentives and priorities it's the same
problem you have in
organizations all the time right like
you have multiple teams trying to work
together to produce that's creative and
parts to give value to organization some
of teams might produce data for another
team um if that's important to the
organization then you get that
prioritized get ceni get centers lined
up make more feel part of the value
they're generating um have kpis or
whatever you want to do whatever your
organization does to incentivize teams
working together one of those happens to
be producing a DAT product with a
contract band it and commit to
committing to maintaining that for the
long term so that business can other
part of business can build on that and
provide value whether that's like an
model reporting or other engineering
teams engineering teams building Day
driv applications doesn't really matter
um so yeah it's just a problem of
incentives and pration like same as same
as any
other
yeah okay sure um I I think that that
also really depends like specifically
when you connect it to the to the data
product part right because when when you
actually own the data product that has a
data contract on top of that and I fully
agree like data contract is
fundamentally about like giving promises
giving guarantees to others about
something that you are offering um so it
definitely has to be the the the data
owner for that matter when you do that
properly with product thinking that
means you offer something of value to
the organization and that is also where
the incentive itself comes from um to
give guarantees to give promises to
engage with your stakeholders to figure
out what they actually need and want and
that is were like this this
incentivization that that Andrew just
said um is often coming from the team
itself that owns it and I've seen this a
couple times now that we we started like
a data contracts initiative internally
and a bunch of teams came to us and said
like hey like we want to properly own
our data we want to offer this as a
product and we want to even understand
who are actually our stakeholders right
and if you then have a data contract in
place and you have something where
people can let's say subscribe to and
sign up on um to like register
themselves as stakeholders all of a
sudden you have like a much better
dependency mapping across the
organization as well and that again then
benefits also the owner because finally
for instance if they need to do a change
they don't just like turn a knob and
break all of production but they
actually know whom to talk to first
because they have like a proper
registered list of
stakeholders yeah one thing is we need
to convince the the data owners sorry
Tom but the we need to convince the data
owners that the benefits
of owning it is actually superior to the
burden of maintaining it and I think
it's not that easy to to to do
actually no and this is it's not it's
not that easy sorry yeah it's not that
easy the um it's a same the interesting
part here is when you compare this to
software engineering no one is actually
asking the question if you say like you
produce a microservice who's going to
own the API yeah right it's the team
that produces the manages and operates
the service right and for some reason
here the analogy totally makes sense and
in data this is this is like oh who owns
the data and as you mentioned initially
it's the Hot Potato you like and the
reason I think why this comes from is
because the whole analytical data
pipelines are coupled together like
spaghetti cat so the one at the end
doesn't know what they're getting so
they cannot take ownership of what
they're producing on top of that so if
you start at the source or at the
natural tendency is if you when you
start with data contracts that you tend
to go earlier and earlier to push this
forward because if you want to take
ownership of everything that you produce
then you need to know what you're
getting in and if that has a contract
then you can be sure you understand that
and so that's how everyone can start
taking ownership and when the Hot Potato
thing uh becomes a lot easier uh if uh
if your Source also has a contract so I
think that's uh that's where it
starts I mean I think that's a great
analogy um and I and I I do want
um you know go a little bit deeper there
because um you know my concern would be
that the the business side of the house
the folks that believe that they're um
you know um initiating the the creation
of the data product or they need to
share the data product with customers or
Partners or clients um like if these
people feel like there's roadblocks
being put up in the way of them just
quickly getting access to the data
because well they know SQL and they can
talk to the database directly um I
curious like in the real world how you
sort of mediate these concerns because
um I mean I think we all as as Engineers
understand the the power and the
potential and the necessity of
establishing these contracts at the
origin of the water supply as Tom said
um but how do we get the rest of the
organization on board when they just
feel like potentially we're throwing
more roadblocks and more rules um in
place that that um you know reduce time
to Market on their side um you know I'd
be curious to hear your thoughts on and
how you've handled this in your own
Orcs it it really depends what role you
you're you're thinking okay for example
a lot of my consumers are data
scientists um and they don't see the
data contract because they they just
don't care but what they're really
interested in it's the and and
discoverability that it's actually
bringing because you're bringing trust
uh you you're
bringing uh detailed information about
the data itself and then they can say
okay well this is actually the data set
I was looking for uh without having to
go through thousands of pages in
Confluence which are probably not even
up to date right so so that's for them
it's kind of a it's kind of an easy win
um and My Hope also is that as it
becomes part of the normal work to
expect a data contract when they're
looking for something
oh so this is to say that data contracts
can promote disc discoverability
yes other other examples of that or or
other aspects of how you win win over
your business facing
teams I I had a very interesting
conversation at a at the data Master
Class recently where somebody said
before like everybody's always talking
about shift left right like you you want
to bring responsibility closer to for
instance where the data is originally
coming from and somebody said that
interesting phrase before you shift left
you need to first shift right because
first you need to actually engage with
those business people who have the
actual data need and you need to First
figure out what is it what what is that
particular need right like what what is
the business use case that's sent
behinds of that like what's the actual
value that you're generating with that
and once you are actually capable of
quantifying that then all of a sudden
the the incentivization to push people
to actually do something about it
becomes much much easier like if if
you're actually coming and saying yeah
like we have this I don't know like4
million use case um but we can only do
it if we have this and this data with
like proper quality um then you can go
to the to the team that's supposed to
own that and like all of a sudden the
conversation becomes comes to a totally
different level than just randomly
picking something that already exists
realizing it breaks at the other day and
then starting to shout at people right
so like like the whole process of like
how also new data is created and how it
is then properly uh covered with with
with contracts for that matter
um comes in from a totally different
angle all of a sudden because the the
business use case itself stands at the
core of everything that you're actually
doing for the
organization well I love that shift
right to shift left um I think that's uh
it's definitely very quotable and very
interesting because we have to remember
that um the systems that we're building
are in service of um of of the end users
at the end of the day anyway so it's uh
that's well
said well let's talk about um how how
how the contracts are actually enforced
because we we touched on who owned them
and I think the the panel is in
agreement that it's definitely the the
producer side of the house um what are
your experiences in actually enforcing
the contracts um are these um are there
systemic ways are there um sort of
policy in review ways um like let's talk
a little bit more um in in the real
world examples of like what goes what
goes wrong when a data contract isn't
fulfilled well the first thing is you've
got to ensure that the owner has kids so
you can kidnap them and then you
threaten to give them back if it doesn't
maintained correctly uh that's that's
that's a to do
Yeah Yeah by
where are you looking for your
kids around here
somewhere
um might be other ways that might be
a more suitable for
workplace um I think
like you can try I don't really like
having reviews my people saying you got
a review from my person be on bot neck I
think b knck r down um he Gatekeepers
and down I think you can automate a lot
this way I think you
can um allow the data producers to
Define very dat contracts you have a
certain amount of C checks on that say
you know whether making a breaking
change or not that might that might cre
an issue um go as far as you like really
and then you can merge it to a platform
and it can be deployed and the interface
can get up dat contract and then you got
your interface that's in syn day
contract at all times and that's what
you need for the start I think
I mean you keep going further really
like like I think we've been saying you
can iterate on this so you could have
when the right data to that interface
they can run some checks on that and
they can get alerts and if the alerts
fail then can they de that like any
other inst they deal with um you can
have checked later in day platform side
in Warehouse side
um I it's possible really you want the
checks to be so that all issues are
localized and the alert is go to data
owner and they can then deal with it
before data goes throughout your data
warehouse and in front of your customers
your own customers um so yeah I
think don't make it sound too
complicated really it can be quite
simple to start St contract
um and just evolve from there and keep
adding more checks more automation but
doing so in a way weot the autonomy of
dat producers to talk to their dat
consumers and provide the DAT product
that they need without central check
asking a DAT governance person or
someone like that to to review every
data set because those people don't have
the context on data they don't
understand your case they're not for
right people to do
that maybe I'm optimistic but I you get
the right people talking together and
give them right toing and the automation
they will do the right
thing yeah makes sense I think I I think
one one one important thing is that it's
it's not only about enforcing a data
contract of course you want to enforce
it but it's also to use it as a
detection tool okay so for example
you've got a data contract on on a on a
pipeline and that that is actually this
this one configuration file soda is
using it to detect the quality issues on
your pipeline detect something and then
notify you the the the time to detection
of an issue is reduced drastically okay
so it's not about oh make sure that it's
in forced but it's about the time you
use to detect the error because this is
in data this is where I've seen the
worst scenario when a software
microservice is not working for example
you've got you've got some you've got
your phone that is ringing quite quickly
in data it can be subtle okay and I've
got horor stories about like you know
two months later oh there's this report
that is in this monthly report that has
not been uh delivered on time but if we
had the right Pipeline and the the right
data contract not even the right
pipeline but just even the right data
contract monitoring this the pipeline
the faulty pipeline then we would have
won like two months okay so and not be
and that that kind of consequences in a
regulatory
environment um can be
drastic yeah that I think that that's
totally valid and also I see that data
constructs are going to shift that even
one step further as you mentioned like
not only notice faster but ensure that
that data just doesn't get in the
circuit breaket pattern is going to be
the norm after data contracts uh are
adopted and I think like if if you do
the comparison there like in a database
like what's the function of database
it's like preventing bad data that
doesn't comply with the schema to get
into it because we've learned that if we
don't understand properly what's in the
database then afterwards it's a big mess
and you don't can't do a lot with it and
here's the same thing like
today in data it's still the norm that
you have like incre incremental data
tables where each bdch is just appended
or just added and then you're even like
those that do data quality on the spot
they will just do it on the incremental
data with a filter but I think data
contracts actually are the driver to say
no let's let's make sure that we run the
data quality checks and all the the data
contract enforcement on that new data
before we actually appended and then uh
there's much more guarantees that you
will only find good data and still get
notified
early and um typically the Tom do you
see the data quality checks um being
written by the same team that's um
producing the data contracts or what
kind of cross team collaboration is
required um in the definition of a data
quality standard since we're on the data
quality topic for a moment yeah so we
see data quality checks coming from all
over the place so the whole business is
involved in in data they all have um
their requirements or their domain
knowledge of the data but then getting
it into the contract and I think also
contracts and ownership the discussion
that we have earlier um is really
helpful because the business those are
the people that drive the requirements
and so what uh what we've invested in is
a is a discussion platform a
collaboration space where the uh
anyone in the business can start a
discussion with the team managing the
contract and so is it the owners the
data producers that are responsible for
the data that can then decide on how
this data quality check should be
implemented because there's a lot of
data quality checks that someone anyone
could just activate or do but then if
you do that at scale sometimes a
uniqueness uh check on like a very large
table is something that the the
engineering team wants to review whether
that's actually appr appropriate or not
um so those kind of uh things make a lot
of sense or like anyone can contribute
to the domain knowledge uh but it's I
think the engineers that have to take
the ownership of making sure that this
all runs uh
properly and and I think that's that's
exactly one of the things that data
contracts is also making like massively
simpler right like like so far again
like we actually using soda and like
we've been uh building data quality
checks for quite a while and like we
really saw um like Trum just said like
it was all over the place right like
sometimes even the the consumers built
their own checks on the input Data
before they start their processing so
that they can for themselves know that
everything is actually according to
Quality because the producers themselves
were not giving them any guarantees
whatsoever um and they didn't even like
know how to set up such kind of things
um so it was like a lot of effort of
like self-control and then when you find
something then push back and tell them
to fix it uh and like absolute hassle
like a massive Loop of of improvement
and this is like really the one thing
where I think like data contracts are
also massively simplifying that because
we also simplifying the interfaces to to
set up something like this right like
you're almost going to an extent of
having like uh like easily language
understandable ways of defining your
checks right like like you I don't know
I I feel like we are going full circle
here because something that we've been
doing in databases already like 30 40
years ago when you actually Define that
something cannot be null or something
can only have like certain values or
something like this right like we didn't
have that for like like like data lakes
and such kind of setups for way too long
but now we are like going back there of
actually saying okay in my contract
definition I tell you like what are the
criteria what are the contraints
constraints that I have and it's like
very easy understandable for human and
then all the the platform tooling comes
in that that that Andro was was was
speaking about earlier to then Auto made
the whole setup and execution in the
back so that you as the data owner don't
even need to worry anymore about like
how does the infrastructure look like
how do I run it how do I monitor it um
you just like Define the contract
platform takes care for you um and then
all you have to do is well wake up when
you get called because your data is
wrong I like Max what you're saying
about about the day L I like to think
that the da L as are a bit like the dark
ages of of data uh you know you we were
we were super structured when we did
relational databases with foreign keys
and things like that as and then we had
the star schema were in Warehouse which
was probably and all the things we are
maybe a little slightly too complex and
then let's open bar with the with the
dayes and and just put everything there
no governance just throw your things
around and I think that's now in the
2020s we are in a phase where we're
taking this thing a little bit more
seriously okay okay maybe data is a new
oil but the thing is nobody does
anything with oil beside refine it okay
and data contracts data products are
actually here to to help that that
process great comments um and I want to
remind the listeners to drop their
questions in the chat um we'll save a
few minutes at the end um time's going
by so fast so um we'll keep the
conversation moving but I'm excited to
get to a couple of audience questions at
the end of the program so I wanted to
talk about um like a real world
implementation scenario um max I think
it was you that talked about starting
small um so I was wondering could you
share with us like how did you actually
Implement your earliest data contracts
at hellofresh like give us a real world
case study um for for a minute or two if
you don't mind so the earliest data
contract was literally written on paper
and signed off and that was about five
years
ago so of course that didn't work at all
um because you are completely lacking
the enforcement right and and this is
like the tough part like if you cannot
control um anybody who's actually
working with the content will have
forgotten about it latest after two
months right and and this is like
something that that has been going on
for a while where yeah I think it was
like around nine months ago so like we
we started like diving super deep into
it of like on the one hand side defining
the standardized format um to to
basically make sure we have something
that that can that is very easily
understandable but and and can be
followed in a very easy way um but at
the same time is machine readable right
and then we I I never spoke about data
contracts in that context I always
immediately spoke about automatable data
contracts right because it was it was so
important to say right from the start we
are giving the tooling to not only have
the standardized interface but to take
that interface and automate literally
everything for you right and that comes
with um the che setup of the checks
again like like solar checks for
instance that we are using there um
setup of like schema validation that you
do up front including all the things for
like monitoring and alerting right um
even depending on criticality of the
data set um if it's low criticality you
get like a ping on slack um if it's high
criticality you actually get like woken
up in the night um whenever that is
necessary and this is like really where
where we started with the core building
blocks right we we we took the open
source contract
um we took that as the as the standard
at the beginning way too complex for us
right like like these these eight points
like if you to take all of them in and
ask your First Data producer to do that
um they they will like run away
screaming but like we've broken it down
to like what were the first and smallest
things that actually mattered for us and
that was like slos schema ownership list
of
stakeholders um and some some uh basic
level description of the of the data
product itself right and that's really
like how we are how how we have started
um and now we are onboarding like more
and more use cases to that very
simplified template for which we already
have the tooling that automates
everything behind the scenes um and now
we are slowly starting to think about
extending it further adding new features
here and there uh cherry picking more of
the things from from from the open
source standard um and this is like like
how we now slowly incrementally adding
new stuff great yeah great example um
appreciate that very incremental
approach and it seems like one of the
pitfalls that you discovered was um sort
of an overe expansive like over an
initial overreach of um essentially
trying to bite off you know more more
than you or your your your team your orc
might be able to chew um in terms of the
detailed specification of the standard
and and simpler is probably um better
with the contract at least initially um
what other sorry for that but like at
the beginning I don't care about pricing
of my
data just one of the aspects right and
but that's exactly like what it's
designed to be I think to to to cherry
pick the parts that are relevant for you
absolutely yeah I think that it's
obvious that every piece of the the the
proposed um you know standard probably
doesn't apply to everyone um JG jump in
no no I agree I'm not taking any offense
with the pricing part and first it's
it's still very basic but but some
companies need it because they have this
in intro dep Department billing and
things like that and and you know and
some people we all we are putting some
burden on the producer of the data okay
we hey you just built this data contract
now or this data product and then and
then the guy the producer is coming back
saying and you want me to OST that part
too and pay for it or for so that that's
that's where the pricing is coming from
okay whether you actually bill or just
just show that it costs some money no
well and and some people and some people
sell data externally I mean that that
that could be the the core part part of
their business
correct it it could be but it was when
we put it in the standard it was not
designed at this point okay it was more
a very naive uh show kind of show and
tell of the pricing it cost because then
you can think about companies like you
know done and Brad street comes to mind
or Compass or or this kind of companies
where we are selling data but it's it's
I think the pricing strategy is more
complex than what we planned originally
so but they yeah makes sense
um what other pitfalls have folks seen
in in practice um with you know your
teams or teams that you've worked with
um when it comes to implementing data
contracts
initially it's more coming from the
users as always a human part of it and I
don't want to blame anyone there but
it's the immediate benefit to a data
owner or to a data engineer is not is
not super obvious and we need to take
care of these people they're doing a
great work uh and they're often
pinpointed when things are falling apart
but then the benefits of doing the
contract is going to come but the thing
is in the meanwhile in the beginning at
least you're asking them to do a lot
more so so there's always this you know
adoption and support of those data
engineers and data
Architects yeah yeah I'd agree I think
you can do the toing quite easily but if
you don't bring every with on that
journey of people so that's where you
kind start have
problems um yeah I'd agree 100% yeah the
the biggest uh Pitfall that I've seen is
not start at the beginning it's like
there's a big back door in every
production application that's its
database and so a lot of analytical data
starts by just being harvested from a
production systems database we make a
copy and we work from that but then the
team actually responsible for that
delivery they don't take ownership
because it was just taken from the back
door um and and they're not aware and so
I think that is a major Pitfall where
companies can focus on is like making
sure that the team is aware that look we
are we we did connect to your data we
harvested it uh even in ways that they
didn't agree with or whatever but if
it's used then it needs to be supported
and it should be in theory a
conversation originally like do you want
to expose your API interface over your
database and if they say no or like
least then you have the conversation but
because that's where ownership uh starts
and I see that as one of the the main
pitfalls that that this triggers the
Cascade of no one can being able to take
ownership yeah yeah that's good point my
initial F day contracts really start
moving away from things like change day
capture or t processes dragging data out
of database and using that interface
because yeah the people people's data
you're taking they don't know what
you're doing they've got no incentive to
make sure it's stable if fact they want
to be a to change the database quickly
and autonomy to into the features um so
I come about odds of what you want when
you're building something more stable so
there's a conflict there um and day
contracts one of the things I wanted to
do that was really move away from that
kind of world of just sucking day to
database hope for best um
AR okay if it's just analytics I don't
think it was because we spent a lot of
money on building analytics and
dashboards but it's okay but these days
F data is now being used to drive
product features to drive either
directly or VI or that drive revenue and
it's not okay for it just built on yeah
on that back
door great well um such great thoughts
and um I want to make sure we have some
time for some audience questions so um
let me dive into a few of those and um
see see what the panel's thoughts are um
Barrett is asking following up on
Andrew's statement that contracts really
must deliver version data does that
inherently imply that the data product
is behind an API interface which returns
Json Panda CSV um if so does that not
mean that there's additional processing
overhead especially if the data set is
large so sort of a performance oriented
question here from Barrett yeah that's a
good question particular when we talk
about theery with API it might sound a
bit like that but that's why I think dat
contracts are different than API where
the interface can be a database table in
data warehouse in b or snow whatever
you're using and that table can be
versioned so um in example my book where
we kind build a a simple date contract
impation it's really simple it's
literally one chapter so it's not over
complicated to build a simple contract
liation we spin up tables in bigy they
have a version which underscore V1
underscore V2 um and your version like
that and when you create a new version
you to create a whole new table you can
manage a migration new version if it's a
breaking change it's non breaking change
obviously you can do lot fiction um so
yeah it does not imply it has to be
over Jason or CSV or some over HTTP
interface or anything like that it could
be a a table in day rout could be a cfus
stream a topic um could be anything you
like really what matters is that the
interface is defined and well managed
through a date
contract
right um Alexi is asking how can I use
data contracts because I don't have any
data pipelines um they they're basically
my data pip plans are toore procedures
in my database so I can't catch stuff
before data ingestion um so what would
your advice be to Alexi as to where to
start his journey with data contracts
the first thing I would start with is
like
um on on the data that you are offering
in the uh in the data database itself um
you can already have a contract on that
as well right like because um I always
think of data contracts as like two
different angles there's like preventive
measures that let you apply before uh
something actually like changes or
breaks um like for instance the braking
schema changes something like this can
can prevented um because um that goes
again through like certain procedures um
that that you can apply there but then
there are also um yeah post publishing
measures I'm I'm still lacking for a
better word there um that basically
check like how the data looks like once
it has been published right and like we
we we talked about it earlier um at the
beginning it might not necessarily be
that you want to prevent every single
breaking change uh across the whole
organization right from the start
because it can also be very intrusive
into the um the day-to-day life of the
developer itself um and you need to
provide a lot of tooling to make that
case easier but you just want to start
with let's say detecting breaking things
earlier right like the the classic
example that I believe jgp mentioned
earlier we had something exactly like
this like a machine learning model that
starts drifting um and then like after
two months you realized that one of the
input data sets was missing a column um
that was required for that model
but by that time you already had like
millions of marketing spent going
somewhere right and like like detecting
these things not after two months but
after like two hours is already making a
massive difference to the business right
so like like even that can already add a
lot of value and then you can still
think about improving
incremental yeah the way that data
contract enforcement tools are made
actually um enable two kind of usages
right and I think that's that's the
applicable here because if there's
stored procedures and you cannot really
like first um isolate your new data
before you actually append it because
it's in the stored procedure then
contracts and enforcement allow you to
do it on the end result then you don't
have your circuit breaker yet but you
can start with a contract on the final
data set if you want and then you run it
after the fact but then as you have um
an opportunity to reorganize your your
pipeline and your sword procedure so
that you can interject uh um the the
check and the verification and the
enforcement on the new data then that's
a refactoring and internal refactoring
which um gives you the extra benefit of
catching it even sooner so I think that
that enables uh contracts definitely
have that capability of just layering it
on top of the existing infrastructure
and then gradually moving it to to more
circuit breaking uh over
time great um well let's take one more
question uh before we wrap since it's
almost the top of the hour um Erica is
asking how are data rights and usage
documented in the standard um example is
given a usage restriction that the
consumer of the data may not publish
data externally within 48 hours after
the data lands as as an example I've
seen other data right standards and
curious how this Compares um so I think
this could be a um odcs question um but
it also could be a a more generic
question right with if one wanted to
implement um sort of a usage restriction
in their own data contracts um so maybe
JG you want to start and if anyone has
anything else to add we'll we'll
take sure so so so Eric one one thing
you can do is it for for that part it
touches service levels okay uh
so in in the service level of section of
the of the of the contract you're saying
things like okay this data cannot be
touched or this data is not available or
what whatever then and the the rules
here are pretty flexible you can you can
Define whatever you want then you've got
to have the right tool that can enforce
it if enforcement is needed okay but it
could be something like a buffer it
could be whatever the technology part
you want to do it but really there's
already this kind of support for service
levels uh We've listed like 12 standard
service level so far but there's room
for uh for improvement thing the way we
put it we put the thing in the in the
data contract is that when we're
thinking about data quality we're
thinking about the seven kind of
standard data quality attributes that
you can find but service level salese
are very creative at think at delivering
plenty of things and Pete as you were
saying about companies that are selling
data they're even more creative so
that's why the service level can be
really what you want and I'm pretty sure
there's a there's an easy way to do it
makes sense well everyone um that's
that's all the time we have um really
appreciate you spending the last hour
with us and sharing your wisdom and
experience with the community um I'm
sure folks can find you on LinkedIn or
Twitter um or X as the case may be these
days and um we'll look forward to seeing
you around the data Community soon so
thanks thanks again for joining
us
[Music]